Shure: 去外面是吗
Shure: Go outside, right?
Jake:在这待着就行
Jake: Just stay here, it's fine.
Shure: 我去外面吧
Shure: I'll go outside.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Katrina: 他好认真他真的好认真
Katrina: He's so serious, he really is so serious.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Nicous:  卧槽卧槽哥哥哥别别吓我你喝多了
Nicous: Whoa whoa, dude, don't scare me, you're drunk.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure: 她在外面唱歌呢你喊不来的
Shure: She's singing outside, you can't call her over.
Katrina:  你的灯灭了耶你的
Katrina: Your light went out, your...
Katrina: 你灯灭了
Katrina: Your light went out.
Lucia: 没电了吧
Lucia: Maybe it's out of battery.
Katrina:  没事算了吧
Katrina: It's fine, forget it.
Katrina:  哎又亮了
Katrina: Oh, it's back on.
Katrina:  哦不对那是他的反光
Katrina: Oh no, that's just the reflection.
Katrina:  对不起哈哈
Katrina: Sorry, haha.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh man.
Shure:  你好
Shure: Hello.
Katrina: 你好
Katrina: Hello.
Katrina:  很高兴认识你
Katrina: Nice to meet you.
Alice: 我还有77
Alice: I still have 77.
Katrina:  公园能干啥
Katrina: What can you do in a park?
Katrina:  野餐啊
Katrina: Picnic?
Shure: 溜达
Shure: Stroll.
Katrina:  散步啊溜达
Katrina: Walk, stroll.
Shure:  公园可以压马路
Shure: You can walk around the park.
Shure:  溜达
Shure: Stroll.
Katrina:  北京有还有啥适合散步的地方吗什刹海
Katrina: Are there other good places to walk in Beijing, like Shichahai?
Shure: 朝阳公园什刹海
Shure: Chaoyang Park, Shichahai.
Shure:  后海
Shure: Houhai.
Katrina:  嗯什刹海跟那后海连在一起
Katrina: Hmm, Shichahai and Houhai are connected.
Shure:  连在一起
Shure: They're connected.
Katrina:  后海有酒吧推荐吗
Katrina: Any bar recommendations in Houhai?
Shure:  你去跳海吧
Shure: You should try Tiaohai.
Katrina:  跳海可以吗
Katrina: Is Tiaohai good?
Katrina:  我经常看他网上说的很好
Katrina: I often see it recommended online.
Shure:  但是我怕也是网红店踩雷
Shure: But I'm afraid it might just be an internet-famous place and disappointing.
Shure:  不不不跳海是一个连锁店
Shure: No, no, Tiaohai is a chain store.
Shure:  你去肯定没错
Shure: You can't go wrong there.
Shure:  你去其他店可能会被坑
Shure: You might get ripped off going to other shops.
Shure:  但是你去跳海肯定没错
Shure: But if you go to Jump Sea, you can't go wrong.
Katrina: 他的消费是有低消吗
Katrina: Do they have a minimum spend there?
Shure:  没没有低消
Shure: No, there's no minimum spend.
Shure:  他是他是一个类似于精酿啤酒吧算是
Shure: It's kind of like a craft beer bar, I guess.
Shure:  算是也不算精酿啤酒吧
Shure: Well, not exactly a craft beer bar.
Shure:  他也有一些果泥啤酒的什么的
Shure: They also have some fruit beers and stuff.
Katrina:  这要自己弄看半天
Katrina: You have to figure it out yourself and watch for a while.
Katrina:  哎他是不是要
Katrina: Hey, is he going to...
Katrina:  他是不是少了散粉啊噢噢
Katrina: Is he missing some loose powder?
Katrina:  哦对定妆喷雾
Katrina: Oh, right, setting spray.
Katrina:  但是我感觉还少了散粉
Katrina: But I still feel like he's missing loose powder.
Nicous: 什么叫散粉等一下她给我讲了
Nicous: What do you mean by loose powder? Wait, she explained it to me.
Shure: 谢冰竹
Shure: Thanks, Bingzhu.
Shure: 你烟
Shure: Your cigarette.
Katrina:  你喝酒他抽烟
Katrina: You drink, he smokes.
Shure: 来一个来一个
Shure: Give me one, give me one.
Katrina:  你会抽烟
Katrina: You know how to smoke?
Katrina:  你会啊
Katrina: You do?
Nicous:  我帮你点来来来
Nicous: I'll light it for you, come on.
Nicous:  老板请享用
Nicous: Boss, please enjoy.
Katrina:  哎呀哎呀哎呀
Katrina: Oh my, oh my, oh my.
Katrina:  你这下真成那种摇
Katrina: Now you're really rocking and rolling.
Katrina:  滚的了就是
Katrina: Like, seriously.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  很厉害很厉害
Katrina: Impressive, impressive.
Shure:  这也没有爆珠吧
Shure: This one doesn't have beads, right?
Nicous:  有爆珠有爆珠食活爆珠
Nicous: It does have beads, like live beads.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Katrina:  散粉眉粉腮红
Katrina: Loose powder, brow powder, blush.
Katrina:  哈哈眼影盘
Katrina: Haha, eyeshadow palette.
Nicous:  他说他自己买的妆前
Nicous: He said he bought the primer himself.
Nicous:  妆前和隔离
Nicous: Primer and base.
Nicous:  嗯对那是散粉吗
Nicous: Hmm, is that loose powder?
Katrina:  不是哈哈
Katrina: No, haha.
Katrina:  那是用在粉底液之前的
Katrina: That's used before foundation.
Nicous: 你有散粉吗
Nicous: Do you have loose powder?
Katrina:  不是你这也太贴心了
Katrina: No, you're too considerate.
Katrina:  看见别人的幸福我就破防
Katrina: Seeing other people's happiness makes me feel vulnerable, you know?
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Shure:  嘿嘿破防吧你就
Shure: Hehe, you're breaking down.
Katrina:  今天真让我大破防啊
Katrina: Today really broke me down.
Katrina:  本来开开心心
Katrina: I was so happy at first.
Nicous: 我来给你介绍好了
Nicous: Let me introduce you.
Katrina:  长得帅的
Katrina: He's handsome.
Katrina:  嗯可以
Katrina: Hmm, okay.
Katrina:  我在我们武汉理工呆四年
Katrina: I stayed at Wuhan University of Technology for four years.
Katrina:  没见到一个帅哥
Katrina: Never saw a handsome guy.
Katrina:  倒也不是眼光高
Katrina: It's not that I have high standards.
Katrina:  我还真的没帅哥
Katrina: There really were no handsome guys.
Nicous:  要多高的
Nicous: How tall should they be?
Katrina:  一米八
Katrina: 1.8 meters.
Nicous: 怎么样这个烟
Nicous: How's this cigarette?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Nicous: 这个烟怎么样
Nicous: How's this cigarette?
Shure: 还行还
Shure: It's okay.
Katrina:  我靠
Katrina: Oh my.
Katrina:  给你拍张艺术照
Katrina: Let me take an artistic photo of you.
Nicous:  不够有万宝路
Nicous: Not as good as Marlboro.
Shure:  可以可以可以
Shure: It's alright.
Katrina:  私下烟酒都来呀
Katrina: You smoke and drink in private too.
Katrina:  哈哈哈特别像我一个表弟
Katrina: Hahaha, you really remind me of my cousin.
Shure:  哎你们都不喝
Shure: Hey, you guys aren't drinking?
Katrina:  再喝晚上还写毕设呢
Katrina: If I drink more, I still have to write my thesis tonight.
Shure:  几点了哥
Shure: What time is it, bro?
Shure:  10点了还写毕设呢
Shure: It's 10 PM, and you still have to write your thesis?
Katrina:  那没别的时间呀
Katrina: There's no other time.
Katrina:  早上起不来
Katrina: I can't get up in the morning.
Katrina:  只有晚上工作
Katrina: I can only work at night.
Shure:  明天早上我叫你
Shure: I'll wake you up tomorrow morning.
Shure:  咱俩一起写毕设
Shure: We'll write the thesis together.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Okay?
Katrina:  几点钟
Katrina: What time?
Shure:  8点钟起写毕设
Shure: 8 AM, we'll start writing the thesis.
Shure:  你写不写
Shure: Are you writing or not?
Katrina:  我靠
Katrina: Oh my.
Shure: 我现在
Shure: Right now...
Shure:  咱再来一杯
Shure: Let's have another drink.
Shure:  然后咱8点起来写毕设
Shure: Then we'll get up at 8 to write the thesis.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Okay?
Katrina:  不
Katrina: No
Katrina:  坚定原则
Katrina: Stick to principles
Shure:  咦好坚定
Shure: Wow, so determined
Katrina:  等我今天把事弄完了
Katrina: Let me finish up today
Katrina:  明天跟你喝
Katrina: I'll drink with you tomorrow
Katrina:  今天是第几天
Katrina: What day is it today?
Katrina:  第第二天
Katrina: It's the second day
Katrina:  还早着呢
Katrina: Still early
Katrina:  明天还要拍那个yesok
Katrina: We have to film that "yesok" tomorrow
Katrina:  yesok
Katrina: Yesok
Katrina:  你今天晚上去学
Katrina: You study it tonight
Katrina:  你来教行吗
Katrina: Can you teach me?
Katrina:  不想教
Katrina: Don't want to teach
Shure:  我可以给你查拍子
Shure: I can help you with the rhythm
Shure:  我查拍子绝对牛逼
Shure: I'm absolutely great at rhythm
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you
Nicous: 你他妈也太浪费钱了吧
Nicous: You're wasting money like crazy
Nicous: 抽这么一点就扔你是人吗
Nicous: Throwing it away after smoking just a little, are you even human?
Shure:  怎么遭哇
Shure: What's the problem?
Katrina:  怎么着吧打一架
Katrina: How about we fight?
Katrina:  其实我觉得这个地方完全可以翻进来
Katrina: Actually, I think we can just jump over here
Katrina:  这里又没有门又没有密码
Katrina: There's no door or password here
Katrina:  哦也是你们帮忙挑的
Katrina: Oh right, you guys helped pick this spot
Nicous: 我们把这片至少看了有十几遍
Nicous: We watched this area at least a dozen times
Katrina:  他的优势是
Katrina: Its advantage is
Nicous: 两个客厅大
Nicous: Two large living rooms
Nicous:  公共区域比较大
Nicous: The common area is pretty big
Nicous: 他还有一个优势是每个人住的地方比较大
Nicous: Another advantage is that everyone has a big living space
Katrina:  嗯我当时
Katrina: Yeah, at the time
Katrina:  我当时一直以为是三个人住一个房间
Katrina: I always thought three people shared one room
Nicous:  差点让你们三个人住一个房间
Nicous: Almost had you three in one room
Shure:  为什么不是三个人住一个房间
Shure: Why not three people in one room?
Nicous:  那你就跟杨老板住一个房间
Nicous: Then you can share a room with Jake
Katrina:  他晚上5点睡你
Katrina: He sleeps at 5 AM
Nicous:  不是三个人是两两
Nicous: It's not three, it's two per room
Katrina:  他5点睡
Katrina: He sleeps at 5
Katrina:  你几点睡
Katrina: What time do you sleep?
Shure:  我以为是跟女嘉宾住一个房间
Shure: I thought I'd be sharing a room with the female guest
Katrina:  这话赶紧给他录下来
Katrina: Quick, record what he just said
Katrina:  给他女朋友发过去
Katrina: Send it to his girlfriend
Shure:  你滚犊子吧你
Shure: Get lost, you!
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure:  哎你知道吗
Shure: Hey, you know what?
Shure:  我我们俩
Shure: We, both of us
Shure:  我俩五一一一起回长春你知道吗
Shure: Both of us are going back to Changchun together on May 1st, you know that?
Katrina:  那这不得见一波家长啊
Katrina: Then you must be meeting the parents, huh?
Nicous: 所以酒喝多了都可以说了
Nicous: So, after drinking too much, everything comes out
Nicous: 你妈说你妈说终于能见到小红帽了
Nicous: Your mom said, finally, she can meet Little Red Riding Hood
Shure:  你知道这个小红帽子梗吗
Shure: Do you know about this Little Red Riding Hood joke?
Nicous: 卧槽我每次跟我女朋友吵架都是我妈哄我女朋友
Nicous: Damn, every time I argue with my girlfriend, it's my mom who comforts her
Katrina:  啊我室友也是
Katrina: Oh, my roommate is the same
Katrina:  就是男生的妈妈来找他
Katrina: The guy's mom comes to find him
Nicous: 因为她不理我了
Nicous: Because she won't talk to me anymore
Katrina:  对就是
Katrina: Exactly
Katrina:  但是但是
Katrina: But, but
Katrina:  这样子的话也有有好也有不好
Katrina: In this case, there are both pros and cons
Katrina:  那要是你以后换女朋友
Katrina: What if you get a new girlfriend later
Katrina:  你妈不得哄下一个
Katrina: Your mom has to comfort the next one?
Nicous: 还真是
Nicous: That's true
Katrina:  唉
Katrina: Sigh
Nicous:  我妈说求你别换
Nicous: My mom says, please don't change
Shure:  我本来本来买的是杭州
Shure: I originally, originally bought a ticket to Hangzhou
Shure:  直接直接接
Shure: Directly, directly
Nicous: 这个不太好哄就是
Nicous: This one's hard to comfort
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure:  我本我本来买的那个杭州
Shure: I originally bought a ticket to Hangzhou
Shure:  直接去长春的那个高铁票
Shure: A direct high-speed rail ticket to Changchun
Katrina:  你女朋友啊
Katrina: Your girlfriend, huh?
Katrina:  哎呀你们俩够抽象的
Katrina: Wow, you two are quite abstract
Katrina:  不是你你们俩
Katrina: I mean, you two
Katrina:  呃你们俩就那个软件上认识以后
Katrina: You two met on that app, and then
Katrina:  那见面了吗
Katrina: Did you meet in person?
Nicous: 网页找的
Nicous: Found her online
Nicous: 见面了啊
Nicous: We met in person
Nicous: 不是这他妈过了一年才见面
Nicous: But it took a year before we met
Katrina:  然后见面就表白在一起了
Katrina: Then you confessed and got together right after meeting?
Nicous: 见面没准备在一起
Nicous: We didn't plan to get together
Nicous: 准备再也不见了
Nicous: We planned to never meet again
Nicous: 后来写了封信就太感人了就在一起了
Nicous: But then I wrote a letter, it was so touching, and we got together.
Katrina:  他给你写的
Katrina: He wrote it for you.
Nicous: 我跟她互相写的
Nicous: We wrote to each other.
Katrina:  唉哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina:  感觉每个人的事情都很神奇
Katrina: It feels like everyone's story is so amazing.
Katrina:  那就是见面了的时候
Katrina: So when you met,
Katrina:  就互相彼此心动了呗
Katrina: you both just fell for each other?
Katrina:  看对眼了呗
Katrina: You liked each other at first sight?
Katrina:  哦确实一开始就异地嘛
Katrina: Oh, right, you started off long-distance.
Katrina:  你不是说很抽象吗你这个
Katrina: Didn't you say it was very abstract?
Katrina:  特别喜欢听别人讲八卦
Katrina: I really love hearing gossip.
Katrina:  因为我在学校圈子其实就我舍
Katrina: Because in my school circle, actually, it's just my dorm
Katrina:  友然后我舍友几个要么就有男朋友
Katrina: mates, and some of them have boyfriends
Katrina:  一直高中谈到现在
Katrina: since high school.
Katrina:  要么就是不跟男的说一句话
Katrina: Or they just don’t talk to guys at all.
Katrina:  就没有没有八卦就是我说我
Katrina: So there's no gossip. I mean,
Katrina:  我在学校里圈子比较小
Katrina: my school circle is pretty small,
Katrina:  就没听见什么八卦
Katrina: so I don't hear much gossip.
Katrina:  我们哎太喜欢认识新的人了
Katrina: We really love meeting new people.
Shure:  我们想想听你的八卦
Shure: We want to hear your gossip.
Katrina:  我就一段
Katrina: I only have one story.
Nicous: 说宝宝早安
Nicous: Say "Good morning, baby."
Nicous:  然后第二天就跟我前女友官宣了
Nicous: Then the next day, I announced it with my ex-girlfriend.
Katrina:  谁谁谁谁
Katrina: Who? Who? Who?
Nicous:  我刚说的第二天说宝宝早安
Nicous: The day after I said "Good morning, baby,"
Nicous:  第二天就跟我前女友有官宣了
Nicous: the next day I announced it with my ex-girlfriend.
Katrina:  你
Katrina: You?
Katrina:  你跟你前女友官宣
Katrina: You announced it with your ex-girlfriend?
Katrina:  暧昧
Katrina: Flirting.
Nicous:  一开始暧昧
Nicous: At first, it was flirting.
Nicous:  后来已经g了
Nicous: Then it ended.
Nicous:  后来他私信不理我
Nicous: Then he ignored my DMs.
Nicous:  他说他在忙
Nicous: He said he was busy.
Nicous:  然后我以为我跟他就是朋友处了
Nicous: So I thought we were just friends.
Nicous:  然后我就直接跟
Nicous: Then I directly
Nicous:  然后后来就跟我前女友认识了
Nicous: later met my ex-girlfriend.
Nicous:  就是不认识了
Nicous: I mean, didn't know her.
Katrina:  也就是说
Katrina: So,
Katrina:  你跟你现女友认识的比你前女友早
Katrina: you knew your current girlfriend before your ex?
Nicous: 早太多了
Nicous: Way before.
Nicous:  然后然后我就直接发过来
Nicous: Then, then I just sent it over.
Nicous:  我也没隐瞒他我就他看见了
Nicous: I didn't hide it from him, he saw it.
Nicous:  然后他就说好吧然后
Nicous: Then he said, "Alright," and...
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Nicous:  过了一段时间过了一段时间
Nicous: After some time, after some time...
Nicous:  他买了个机票直接来北京
Nicous: He bought a plane ticket and came straight to Beijing.
Nicous:  他然后他到了晚上跟我讲他到了
Nicous: Then he arrived at night and told me he was here.
Nicous:  让我晚上出来接他
Nicous: He asked me to pick him up at night.
Katrina:  但是那时你分手了吗
Katrina: But had you broken up at that time?
Nicous:  没分的我刚来北京
Nicous: No, I had just come to Beijing.
Nicous:  然后关键最惆怅的是我他妈睡着了
Nicous: And the worst part is, I fell asleep.
Nicous:  没看见嗯我刚起来他飞走了吧哦
Nicous: I didn't see him. When I woke up, he had left.
Katrina:  但是我觉得这女生还蛮有勇气的
Katrina: But I think that girl was pretty brave.
Nicous:  然后后来就都互删了
Nicous: And then we just deleted each other.
Katrina:  互删了后来又加上了
Katrina: Deleted each other, then added back again?
Nicous:  后来我女朋友老出轨
Nicous: Later, my girlfriend kept cheating on me.
Nicous:  我就不想跟我女朋友谈了
Nicous: I didn't want to be with her anymore.
Nicous:  但是我就把他加回来了
Nicous: So I added her back.
Nicous:  然后但是那时候没想跟他谈恋爱
Nicous: But at that time, I didn't want to date her.
Nicous:  我一直都是加回来了
Nicous: I just added her back.
Nicous:  然后抱歉一下干嘛
Nicous: And apologized.
Katrina:  但是你那也有点像就
Katrina: But you were kind of like...
Katrina:  在他的视角有点像断崖式暧昧耶
Katrina: From her perspective, it was like a sudden drop in affection.
Katrina:  就是本来暧昧很好的然后突然跟别人
Katrina: Things were going well, and then suddenly you were with someone else.
Katrina:  四天四天就能代表什么
Katrina: Four days, what can four days represent?
Shure:  四天我这四年里
Shure: Four days, in my four years...
Katrina:  我这五年的
Katrina: In my five years...
Shure:  不喝点了吗
Shure: Didn't you drink something?
Shure:  雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan.
Katrina:  你给我整点呗
Katrina: Can you get me something?
Shure:  给你整点
Shure: Get you something.
Choiszt: 修硕修硕
Choiszt: Shure, Shure.
Shure: 啊怎么了
Shure: Yeah, what's up?
Choiszt: 他在上边扫呢
Choiszt: He's sweeping upstairs.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Choiszt:  你要上去干嘛
Choiszt: Why are you going upstairs?
Shure:  我我我上去取点喝的
Shure: I'm going to get some drinks.
Choiszt:  靖康
Choiszt: Jingkang.
Choiszt: 那个修硕上来去客厅取点东西
Choiszt: Shure went upstairs to get something from the living room.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  我靠你给我少搞一点点
Katrina: Damn it, give me a break.
Katrina:  我等会他妈毕设写不完了
Katrina: I'll never finish my thesis at this rate.
Katrina:  你前女友是表演型人格吗
Katrina: Is your ex-girlfriend an attention seeker?
Katrina:  啊你俩谁也不缺啊
Katrina: Well, neither of you are missing out.
Katrina:  他分了你也分了
Katrina: She broke up with you, and you broke up with her.
Katrina:  然后你俩在一起了
Katrina: And now you two are together.
Katrina:  怎么不算一种缘分呢
Katrina: Isn't that kind of fate?
Katrina:  我靠你给我搞这么多东西
Katrina: Damn it, you gave me so much.
Katrina:  晚上要一直上厕所
Katrina: I'll be running to the bathroom all night.
Nicous: 我初恋在我初二的时候
Nicous: I had my first love in the second year of middle school.
Katrina:  看柚子好不好喝哈
Katrina: Let's see if this grapefruit juice is good.
Katrina:  哎还行
Katrina: Hmm, it's alright.
Katrina:  感觉比橙汁好喝
Katrina: Feels better than orange juice.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yep.
Katrina: 但是单喝这个觉得没有橙汁好喝
Katrina: But drinking it alone isn't as good as orange juice.
Shure:  他那个西柚和橙汁
Shure: Both grapefruit and orange juice are pretty good.
Shure:  都是比较比较不错的
Shure: They're both really nice.
Shure: 咦
Shure: Ew.
Shure:  谁要来打扰我的乌托邦
Shure: Who's interrupting my utopia?
Shure:  我马上掏出我的枪
Shure: I'm gonna pull out my gun.
Nicous: 我就是上了大学才觉得我初中那些不是事
Nicous: It wasn't until I went to college that I realized middle school stuff wasn't a big deal.
Shure: 知道这这首叫什么吗
Shure: Do you know what this song is called?
Shure:  谁要来打扰我的乌托邦
Shure: Who's interrupting my utopia?
Shure:  我马上掏出我的枪
Shure: I'm gonna pull out my gun.
Katrina: 初二那时候算什么
Katrina: What does middle school matter?
Katrina: 谈恋爱个毛线
Katrina: It's just puppy love.
Nicous: 全都什么都做了然后
Nicous: We did everything, and then...
Katrina: 初中的时候啊
Katrina: In middle school?
Shure:  初中的时候
Shure: In middle school.
Katrina: 你好开放
Katrina: You're so open.
Nicous: 然后当时
Nicous: And then...
Nicous: 我他妈开放度吧就是
Nicous: I was so open because...
Nicous:  就是他要的
Nicous: It was what she wanted.
Nicous: 我当时觉得我已经略微的
Nicous: I felt like I was already a bit...
Katrina: 定了
Katrina: Settled.
Nicous: 定了
Nicous: Settled.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Nicous: 结果她听我跟你说她后来跟我好多好朋友纠缠
Nicous: But she ended up messing around with a lot of my good friends.
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina: 我觉得你这人就是也有点惨你知道吧
Katrina: I think you're just kind of unlucky, you know?
Nicous: 关键最抽象的是
Nicous: The key point is the most abstract thing.
Nicous: 那些好朋友都是我推的因为我觉得无所屌谓
Nicous: I pushed all those good friends away because I didn't care at all.
Nicous: 就是有个人说
Nicous: So someone said
Katrina: 这正好放一首make friends
Katrina: This is just the right time to play "make friends."
Nicous: 你能不能推一下
Nicous: Can you push it a bit?
Shure:  乌托邦我想了一首歌
Shure: I thought of a song for Utopia.
Nicous: 然后后来又有一个好朋友说有问题哥们
Nicous: And then another good friend said there was a problem, bro.
Katrina:  我初中的时候还在暗恋别人
Katrina: I was secretly in love with someone in middle school.
Katrina:  暗恋别人
Katrina: Secretly in love.
Katrina: 不知道为什么
Katrina: I don't know why.
Katrina:  说就是就是
Katrina: Just, just
Katrina:  喜欢找人说话不知道怎么把人吓成那样
Katrina: I liked talking to people but didn't know why I scared them.
Katrina:  因为因为他从来身边没有女生
Katrina: Because he never had any girls around him.
Katrina:  然后我在想
Katrina: And then I thought
Katrina:  我喜欢三年不会是
Katrina: I liked him for three years, could it be
Shure:  都他妈是姐妹
Shure: They are all like sisters.
Katrina:  而且又不会有这种
Katrina: And there's none of that
Katrina:  刚去成都的时候找我舍友
Katrina: When I first went to Chengdu, I looked for my roommate.
Katrina:  我舍友就带着他们陈启的那个闺蜜哇
Katrina: My roommate brought his best friend from Chenqi, wow.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: Just
Katrina:  刚好在他们陈启那后面的小吃街里
Katrina: Right in the small food street behind Chenqi.
Katrina:  吃饭他说他说你看嘛
Katrina: We were eating, and he said, look,
Katrina:  这也是我们体院比较有名的那
Katrina: This is also quite famous in our sports institute.
Katrina:  哈哈哈我舔你知道吗
Katrina: Haha, I was drooling, you know?
Katrina:  舔了以后就还要还要call back
Katrina: After drooling, I had to call back.
Katrina: 我那个舍友
Katrina: My roommate
Katrina:  就你在图书馆crush
Katrina: You were crushing in the library.
Katrina:  在我们这算算下流货势
Katrina: In our place, it counts as being a player.
Katrina:  哈哈陈启真好多帅哥
Katrina: Haha, there are so many handsome guys in Chenqi.
Katrina:  嗯感觉太潮了你知道吗就是感觉自己配不上
Katrina: Yeah, it felt so trendy, you know? Like I wasn't worthy.
Katrina:  真是太潮了
Katrina: It was just too trendy.
Katrina:  然后一个个一米八
Katrina: And each one was 1.8 meters tall.
Katrina:  然后那种走路
Katrina: And the way they walked
Katrina:  就是那种体育生走路
Katrina: Like sports students walking.
Shure:  谢冰竹来一杯吗
Shure: Xie Bingzhu, want a drink?
Katrina:  然后那个双开门
Katrina: And then that double door.
Shure:  走
Shure: Let's go.
Shure:  这悲伤玩具
Shure: This sad toy.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  一个也很不错的乐队
Shure: It's also a pretty good band.
Choiszt:  我不知道他会不会再来
Choiszt: I don't know if he will come again.
Choiszt:  一楼再扫一遍哎
Choiszt: Sweep the first floor again.
Nicous: 不是抽这个抽这个
Nicous: Not this one, this one.
Shure: 我我我抽这个就好了
Shure: I'll just take this one.
Shure: 火火火
Shure: Fire, fire, fire.
Shure: 我自己来我自己来
Shure: I'll do it myself, I'll do it myself.
Katrina: 就是玩了一圈
Katrina: Just played a round.
Katrina: 只要有一个抽烟的
Katrina: As long as there's one smoker.
Choiszt: 让我来品鉴一下
Choiszt: Let me have a taste.
Katrina: 后面都会慢慢抽
Katrina: The rest will gradually smoke too.
Nicous: 我抽烟是因为我3月份压力太大了
Nicous: I smoke because I was too stressed in March.
Katrina: 什么时候压力
Katrina: When were you stressed?
Nicous: 我3月份开始抽
Nicous: I started smoking in March.
Shure:  不
Shure: No.
Shure:  我是因为整个圈子都要抽
Shure: I smoke because everyone in the circle does.
Shure:  我我我没有
Shure: I, I, I can't help it.
Shure:  没有办法
Shure: No way.
Katrina: 哦那你为啥不喝酒呢
Katrina: Oh, then why don't you drink?
Katrina: 哦会耽误事是吧
Katrina: Oh, it would mess things up, right?
Shure:  不
Shure: No.
Shure: 喝酒是让你快乐
Shure: Drinking makes you happy.
Nicous:  但是抽烟能让人
Nicous: But smoking can make you
Nicous:  冷静就我
Nicous: calm down, just like me.
Shure:  你滚吧
Shure: Get lost.
Nicous: 我也记得有一次要面试
Nicous: I remember once I had an interview.
Nicous: 然后我他妈一晚上没咋睡
Nicous: And I didn't sleep well the whole night.
Nicous: 在准备面试
Nicous: Preparing for the interview.
Nicous: 然后我没办法很困嘛
Nicous: I was so tired.
Nicous: 然后搁那抽几根就可以了
Nicous: Then I smoked a few cigarettes, and it was fine.
Shure:  别听他的
Shure: Don't listen to him.
Shure:  喝酒就好
Shure: Just drink.
Katrina:  但是喝酒确实
Katrina: But drinking really
Katrina:  比如说晚上有事
Katrina: If there's something going on at night
Katrina:  让人压力又很大喝酒就晕就干不了了
Katrina: Drinking makes you dizzy and you can't do anything.
Shure: 是的
Shure: That's true.
Shure:  非常好的状态
Shure: In great condition.
Katrina:  当时你知道
Katrina: Back then, you know,
Katrina:  我刚分手那会
Katrina: When I had just broken up,
Katrina:  我室友他们没有offer
Katrina: My roommates didn't have offers.
Katrina:  然后就因为我们室友基本都保研
Katrina: And because most of my roommates were going to grad school,
Katrina:  然后然后就没人说话
Katrina: So no one was talking.
Katrina:  没人说话我就他们天天在图书馆
Katrina: No one was talking, and they were in the library every day.
Katrina:  我就一个人在宿舍
Katrina: So I was alone in the dorm.
Katrina:  卧槽我前男友
Katrina: Damn, my ex-boyfriend...
Katrina:  够抽象我跟你讲
Katrina: So abstract, I tell you.
Katrina:  我前男友当时嗯
Katrina: My ex-boyfriend at the time, um...
Katrina:  他你知道
Katrina: He, you know,
Katrina:  我们分手的导火索是一件非常非常小的事
Katrina: The trigger for our breakup was something very, very small.
Katrina: 他觉得我不配他看一个东西就一个视频什么的
Katrina: He thought I didn't deserve him watching something, like a video or something.
Katrina:  因为我们异地恋有的时候会一起看综艺
Katrina: Because we were in a long-distance relationship, sometimes we'd watch shows together.
Katrina:  就是开腾讯会议嘛然后呢
Katrina: We used Tencent Meeting for that, and then...
Katrina:  他觉得我不陪他看那个短视频
Katrina: He thought I didn't watch that short video with him.
Katrina:  因为我觉得我刚看过
Katrina: Because I felt like I had just watched it,
Katrina:  我给他推荐
Katrina: I recommended it to him.
Katrina:  他就跟我就是那种撒娇的人
Katrina: He was acting all cute, like...
Katrina:  就是不嘛
Katrina: No, I must watch it with my girlfriend.
Katrina:  我一定要有女朋友看
Katrina: But I didn't buy it.
Katrina:  但是我不吃这一套
Katrina: You know, I never act cute with my boyfriend.
Katrina:  你知道我也从来不跟我男朋友撒娇
Katrina: You know, I never act cute.
Nicous: 懂了你就是不爱了
Nicous: Got it, you just didn't love him anymore.
Katrina:  我从来不撒娇
Katrina: I never act cute.
Katrina:  我再次总结
Katrina: I'll summarize again,
Katrina:  就是再怎么喜欢我都不撒娇
Katrina: No matter how much I like someone, I won't act cute.
Katrina:  我撒不出来
Katrina: I just can't do it.
Katrina:  我觉得很恶心
Katrina: I find it disgusting.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina:  然后然后就这件事其实也没多大人
Katrina: So, this thing wasn't a big deal.
Katrina:  就晚上稍微说一下就过了
Katrina: Just mentioned it a bit at night, and it passed.
Katrina:  然后他就一直就那死态度
Katrina: Then he kept that attitude.
Katrina:  然后就一直不说话
Katrina: He just wouldn't talk.
Katrina:  然后到第二天
Katrina: And then the next day,
Katrina:  等到第二天下午2点多回去
Katrina: The next afternoon, around 2 PM, he came back.
Katrina:  而且我们已经是在一起5年了
Katrina: And we had been together for 5 years.
Katrina:  就是这个相处模式
Katrina: This was our way of getting along.
Katrina:  还是这个样子
Katrina: Still the same.
Katrina:  就是冷战
Katrina: It's like a cold war.
Katrina:  他没多大点事他都不愿
Katrina: He won't even budge over the smallest things.
Katrina:  意低头那种
Katrina: He refuses to back down.
Katrina:  然后我我晚上两点没睡着
Katrina: So, I was up at 2 AM, couldn't sleep.
Katrina:  我正准备给他发小作文呢
Katrina: I was about to send him a long message.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  就是复盘复盘
Katrina: Just to recap, go over things.
Katrina:  然后呢然后发现突然一下就说
Katrina: And then I suddenly thought, why should I always be the one to send it first?
Katrina:  凭什么又是我发
Katrina: Haha, why should I always be the first one?
Katrina:  哈哈凭什么又是我先发
Nicous: Because he never backs down, right?
Nicous: 因为他从来不低头是吧
Katrina: Yeah, he basically never does.
Katrina:  基本不低头
Nicous: My ex once told me something.
Nicous:  最后前女友给我讲过一个
Nicous: She said...
Nicous:  讲过一句话嗯
Nicous: She'd never back down to me in this life.
Nicous:  不然这辈子不会向我低头
Nicous: I told her to get lost.
Nicous:  我说你滚
Nicous: Get out.
Katrina:  就是大家有有事好像
Katrina: It's like everyone has some issue.
Katrina:  其实我是那种吃软不吃硬的
Katrina: Honestly, I'm the type who responds better to kindness.
Katrina:  你只要给我稍微给我一个台阶下
Katrina: If you just give me a way out, even a little.
Katrina:  我就马上我们俩好好沟通了
Katrina: I'll immediately be ready to communicate well.
Katrina:  就过了我不记仇那种
Katrina: I didn't hold a grudge and just moved on.
Katrina:  然后但是
Katrina: But then,
Katrina:  然后我第二天知道他有早八
Katrina: The next day, I knew he had an 8 AM class,
Katrina:  但是他一直没有给我发消息
Katrina: But he still hadn't messaged me.
Katrina:  就是到下午两两3点
Katrina: It was around 2 or 3 PM,
Katrina:  然后我就给他就把我小作文打打回去
Katrina: So I sent him a long message.
Katrina:  然后就当时也比较失望
Katrina: I was pretty disappointed at that time,
Katrina:  然后我就提了分手嘛
Katrina: And I broke up with him.
Katrina:  然后然后呢
Katrina: Then,
Katrina:  他就说啊
Katrina: He said,
Katrina:  他回的特别幼稚你知道吗
Katrina: His reply was so childish, you know?
Katrina:  他说什么
Katrina: He said,
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈永远在等这一句
Katrina: Hahaha, always waiting for this line.
Katrina:  我当时这句我觉得特下头
Katrina: That line really turned me off.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Katrina:  你看我给你分析的问题了吗
Katrina: Did you see the issues I pointed out?
Katrina:  你就哈哈哈
Katrina: And he just laughed.
Katrina:  他这句话
Katrina: That line,
Katrina:  一下又把这个道德包袱一下甩我身上
Katrina: Just shifted all the moral burden onto me,
Katrina:  说我我总提分手
Katrina: Saying I always talk about breaking up.
Katrina:  我我靠
Katrina: I, I can't believe it.
Katrina:  我几年没提分手了
Katrina: I haven't mentioned breaking up for years.
Katrina:  大一的时候喜欢你的
Katrina: I liked you back in freshman year.
Katrina:  然后后来
Katrina: And then later...
Katrina:  那我话还没说完呢
Katrina: I hadn't even finished my sentence.
Katrina:  我说你看我们俩问题了吗
Katrina: I said, do you see our problems?
Katrina:  然后我就把这发过去
Katrina: Then I sent this over.
Katrina:  然后就红感叹号了
Katrina: And then got a red exclamation mark.
Katrina:  然后红感叹号以后
Katrina: After the red exclamation mark...
Katrina:  然后再说看其他平台吧
Katrina: I said, let's check other platforms.
Katrina:  都是红感叹号
Katrina: They were all red exclamation marks.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  抖音QQ
Katrina: TikTok, QQ...
Katrina:  然后包括我的b站
Katrina: Including my Bilibili account.
Katrina:  然后所有都被拉黑了
Katrina: Everything was blocked.
Nicous:  蓄谋已久
Nicous: Preplanned.
Katrina:  非常的侮辱人
Katrina: Very insulting.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina:  然后我就就觉得无所谓了
Katrina: I just felt like it didn't matter anymore.
Katrina:  算了算了
Katrina: Whatever, whatever.
Katrina:  就这样吧
Katrina: It is what it is.
Katrina:  然后等他十天后直接给我打个电话说
Katrina: Then ten days later, he called me and said...
Katrina:  他到武汉了
Katrina: He was in Wuhan.
Katrina:  我说就是我
Katrina: I said, it's just me.
Katrina:  那那十天就一直吃不好睡不好啥的
Katrina: Those ten days, I couldn't eat or sleep well.
Katrina:  就是你明明理性上会觉得
Katrina: You know, rationally you think...
Katrina:  你们俩在一起确实比较痛苦
Katrina: Being together is really painful.
Katrina:  就没必要在一起了
Katrina: There's no need to stay together.
Katrina:  但是你晚上的时候
Katrina: But at night...
Katrina:  还是会想到以前开心的事情
Katrina: You still think about the happy times.
Katrina:  因为觉得哎
Katrina: Because you think, hey...
Katrina:  怎么就5年就走到现在这个地步了
Katrina: How did we get to this point after five years?
Katrina:  好歹也是学生时代
Katrina: After all, it was our student days.
Katrina:  就这样就跟自己走上来
Katrina: And then we walked through it together.
Katrina:  然后呢就在前一天刚要复盘完
Katrina: Then, just the day before, I was about to finish reflecting.
Katrina:  就觉得就克服过去了
Katrina: I felt like I had overcome it.
Katrina:  然后他第二天给我打电话说到武汉站
Katrina: Then the next day he called and said he was at Wuhan Station.
Katrina:  然后到武汉站了以后
Katrina: After he got to Wuhan Station...
Katrina:  我就说那天哪见面呢
Katrina: I asked, where should we meet?
Katrina:  感觉特奇怪你知道吗
Katrina: It felt so strange, you know?
Katrina:  饭也不想跟他吃
Katrina:  我就说那你来我们学校吧
Katrina: So I said, why don't you come to our school?
Katrina:  来学校操场走一圈
Katrina: Come and walk around the school field.
Katrina:  走一圈看他当时那样子特别惨
Katrina: We walked around, and he looked so miserable back then.
Katrina:  就是就是
Katrina: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  哈哈哈整个人非常颓废你知道吗
Katrina: Haha, he looked totally defeated, you know?
Katrina:  我说哎呦这个死样子我真服了
Katrina: I was like, oh my, I can't believe how pathetic he looked.
Katrina:  就是嗯
Katrina: Like, um...
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: Just...
Katrina:  整个人就搞得像那种抑郁症一样
Katrina: He looked like he was depressed or something.
Katrina:  就是就这样锤的
Katrina: Just totally beaten down.
Katrina:  然后他跟我说
Katrina: Then he told me,
Katrina:  他这10天不找我是因为他的胃
Katrina: He didn't contact me for 10 days because of his stomach issues.
Katrina:  肠胃不舒服
Katrina: His stomach was upset.
Katrina:  然后不是有情绪器官吗
Katrina: Isn't there something called emotional organs?
Katrina:  就情绪不好
Katrina: He was in a bad mood.
Katrina:  然后导致肠胃不舒服
Katrina: Which caused his stomach problems.
Katrina:  就去校医院一直呃检查来着
Katrina: So he went to the school hospital for a checkup.
Katrina:  我说你不会加个微信吗
Katrina: I said, why couldn't you just add me on WeChat?
Katrina:  你说但凡想想挽回一点
Katrina: If you wanted to fix things even a little,
Katrina:  你都可以加个微信说一下
Katrina: You could've added me on WeChat and said something.
Katrina:  哎就我们稍微冷静一下
Katrina: Like, we should take a break,
Katrina:  但是我并不是想真的和你分手对吧
Katrina: But I don't actually want to break up, right?
Katrina: 就是他这种话死都不说嘛然后
Katrina: But he wouldn't say that even if it killed him, and then
Katrina:  现在过来以后装什么深情呢
Katrina: Now he's acting all sentimental.
Katrina:  然后又说
Katrina: And then he said,
Shure: 多少
Shure: How much?
Katrina:  重庆大学
Katrina: Chongqing University.
Shure:  我听的长春大学
Shure: I heard Changchun University.
Katrina:  然后他又跟我说
Katrina: Then he told me,
Katrina: 那天晚上他那边显示他结尾我这边显示我结尾
Katrina: That night, his end showed he ended it, my end showed I ended it.
Katrina:  所以我们俩就是死锁你知道吗
Katrina: So we were both stuck, you know?
Katrina: 互相等对方的消息
Katrina: Waiting for the other to make a move.
Katrina: 他那边显示他结尾我这边显示我结尾
Katrina: His end showed he ended it, my end showed I ended it.
Shure:  想想我们了吗杨老板
Shure: Did you think about us, Jake?
Jake:想你们了想你了
Jake: I thought about you guys, really did.
Shure:  来来坐坐一会坐一会
Shure: Come on, come sit for a bit.
Shure:  给杨老板拿拿凳子来
Shure: Get a chair for Jake.
Shure:  谁要来打扰我的乌托邦
Shure: Who wants to disturb my utopia?
Jake:明晚烤串吧要不
Jake: How about we have a barbecue tomorrow night?
Shure:  明晚烤串
Shure: BBQ tomorrow night
Shure:  可以
Shure: Sounds good
Katrina: 我看了就那个西海子公园
Katrina: I checked out that Xihai Park
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Katrina: 感觉一下午差不多了
Katrina: I think a whole afternoon would be enough
Katrina: 不要门票
Katrina: No entrance fee
Jake:好
Jake: Great
Shure: 明天明天明天明天
Shure: Tomorrow, tomorrow, tomorrow, tomorrow
Shure: 那明天下午找找
Shure: We'll look for some people in the afternoon
Shure: 找点人陪我买
Shure: To help me buy
Shure: 买点肉什么的
Shure: Some meat and stuff
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Sure thing
Shure: OK
Katrina: 那明天就这两件大的事就够了
Katrina: Then those two big tasks for tomorrow should be enough
Jake:早上你们交换礼物
Jake: You guys exchange gifts in the morning
Jake:今天不交了没电了
Jake: No gifts today, we're out of power
Katrina: 没电了
Katrina: No power
Shure:  来走一个
Shure: Let's go for a walk
Shure:  没电了
Shure: No power
Katrina: 我是摘下来感觉我换到了另一个世界
Katrina: I took it off and felt like I was in another world
Jake: 充会电吧
Jake: Charge it for a while
Jake:然后一会讲一下就是房间准备
Jake: And then we'll talk about preparing the rooms
Jake: 就吹吹牛B就结束了
Jake: Just chat and wrap it up
Katrina: 就是讲自己
Katrina: Just talk about ourselves
Jake:想怎么布置
Jake: How to arrange the rooms
Katrina:  那我去充电
Katrina: I'll go charge it
Katrina:  我的线哦我的线在兜里
Katrina: My cable, oh my cable is in my pocket
Jake:就一会我们讲讲自己
Jake: So we'll chat about ourselves later
Jake: 房间怎么安排
Jake: And how to arrange the rooms
Jake: 今天就结束了
Jake: And then we're done for today
Jake: 然后明天早上交换礼物
Jake: Then exchange gifts in the morning
Jake: 呃然后下午就去他们说的公园是吧
Jake: Uh, and then we'll go to the park they mentioned in the afternoon, right?
Jake: 你们讨论过吗
Jake: Did you guys discuss it?
Lucia: 我们没讨论出去什么公园
Lucia: We didn't discuss which park to go to
Lucia: 因为不知道附近有什么公园
Lucia: Because we don't know what parks are nearby
Alice: 那一波讨论了
Alice: That group discussed it
Jake: 那你们没有讨论
Jake: So you guys didn't discuss
Alice: 都可以
Alice: Anything is fine
Lucia: 对我们follow他们的idea
Lucia: Yeah, we'll follow their idea
Jake:挺好
Jake: Sounds good
Jake: 那明天就这样
Jake: So, let's do it this way tomorrow.
Jake: 主要是等快递吧
Jake: Mainly waiting for the delivery, right?
Jake: 就是快递周五到大概会吗
Jake: The delivery will arrive around Friday, right?
Jake: 你们如果有快递的话
Jake: If you guys have a delivery.
Alice: 我们那个布置是需要落地的吗
Alice: Does our setup need to be on-site?
Lucia: 需要落地吗
Lucia: Does it need to be on-site?
Alice: 落地的话不一定能到吧
Alice: If it's on-site, it might not arrive on time.
Lucia: 对那感觉
Lucia: Yeah, it feels like...
Lucia: 周六快的话周六应该能到
Lucia: If we're fast, it should arrive by Saturday.
Lucia: 周三最快也得明天才能发货嘛对吧
Lucia: The earliest they can ship is tomorrow, right?
Alice: 对
Alice: Yeah.
Alice: 有点呛
Alice: It's a bit tight.
Lucia: 照片墙
Lucia: Photo wall.
Alice:哎呦卧槽
Alice: Oh, damn.
Katrina:  讲到哪了
Katrina: Where did we leave off?
Nicous:  讲到你们在操场见面了两个人死锁
Nicous: You were talking about meeting at the playground, and you two were deadlocked.
Katrina: 他说呃其实有很多误会的存在
Katrina: He said, uh, there were actually a lot of misunderstandings.
Katrina: 但是
Katrina: But...
Katrina: 就是你会觉得异地恋已经很艰难了
Katrina: You feel like long-distance relationships are already hard enough.
Katrina: 然后老天爷好像就在故意设绊子一样
Katrina: And it feels like fate is intentionally setting obstacles.
Katrina: 然后包括当时我的微博只有他知道
Katrina: And back then, only he knew about my Weibo.
Katrina: 微博就当那日记本写了
Katrina: I treated Weibo like my diary.
Katrina: 然后我这边显示他把我拉黑了
Katrina: Then it showed that he blocked me.
Katrina: 就我看不了他的主页
Katrina: I couldn't see his profile.
Katrina: 然后他他跟我说他没拉黑
Katrina: And he told me he didn't block me.
Katrina: 谁也不知道
Katrina: No one knows.
Nicous: 那肯定是他在骗人
Nicous: He must be lying.
Katrina: 但是我就是不相信他骗人
Katrina: But I just don't believe he's lying.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 就是我觉得他他是一个人品不错的人
Katrina: I think he's a decent person.
Nicous: 后来呢又没有同意分了
Nicous: So, did you agree to break up later?
Katrina: 他哎
Katrina: He, ugh...
Katrina: 他他当时也死装了
Katrina: He was stubborn back then.
Katrina: 他跑过来跟我说啊
Katrina: He came to me and said...
Katrina: 我当时过来不是
Katrina: I didn't come back then because...
Jake:灭了呀啊
Jake: It was over, right?
Katrina: 他自己也说了这话对吧
Katrina: He said it himself, right?
Katrina: 然后后来我就去接触新的男生了
Katrina: Then I started meeting new guys.
Katrina: 然后他考研过后他也开始给我发短信
Katrina: And after his exams, he started texting me again.
Katrina:  发短信
Katrina: Texting me.
Jake:他考哪去
Jake: Where is he taking the exam?
Katrina:  他考本校吧
Katrina: He's probably taking it here.
Katrina:  他本来是重庆大学啊
Katrina: He was originally at Chongqing University.
Katrina:  还有就是
Katrina: And also...
Katrina:  我觉得我跟他未来规划完全不一样
Katrina: I feel like our future plans are totally different.
Katrina:  因为他当时他考研择校比我早嘛
Katrina: Because he chose his grad school earlier than me.
Katrina:  就是关于就是我们俩这个分支问题
Katrina: It's about the issue of our different paths.
Katrina:  我们本来还是想大家往一个地方跑
Katrina: Originally, we wanted to head to the same place.
Katrina:  就一个地域吧
Katrina: Like the same region.
Katrina:  中部东部什么的
Katrina: Central or Eastern China or something.
Shure:  那你们是考虑的很很远一些是吗
Shure: So you guys were thinking quite far ahead, huh?
Katrina:  我已经就是
Katrina: I already...
Katrina:  我觉得当时觉得没什么
Katrina: I thought there was no problem at the time.
Katrina:  我谈恋爱就是没什么问题就能相处啊
Katrina: I felt like there were no issues in our relationship, we could get along.
Katrina:  就能继续下去啊
Katrina: We could keep going.
Katrina:  然后他
Katrina: And then he...
Katrina:  他就没什么规划的包括他考研的
Katrina: He didn't really have any plans, even for his grad school.
Katrina:  包括他考研择校还还是我问他
Katrina: Even choosing his grad school, I had to ask him.
Katrina:  我说你打算考哪个
Katrina: I asked him where he was planning to go.
Katrina:  就说我们俩尽量往一个地方就
Katrina: I suggested we try to go to the same place.
Katrina:  我可能更希望男生会有担当一点
Katrina: I guess I hoped he would take on a bit more responsibility.
Katrina:  就去计划一些这些事
Katrina: Like planning these things.
Katrina:  可能他是p人吧
Katrina: Maybe he's a P type person.
Katrina:  我当时没有研究MBTI啊这种东西
Katrina: I hadn't studied MBTI stuff back then.
Katrina:  你知道吧
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  然后我就希望
Katrina: So I just hoped...
Katrina:  我们俩就是有一个明确的规划
Katrina: That we could have a clear plan together.
Katrina:  要不然就异地遥遥无期啊
Katrina: Otherwise, a long-distance relationship would be endless.
Katrina: 他研究生跟我就越隔越远
Katrina: His grad school and mine would just get further apart.
Katrina:  武汉到重庆变成南京到重庆
Katrina: Wuhan to Chongqing became Nanjing to Chongqing.
Katrina:  然后他可能要他
Katrina: And then maybe he...
Katrina:  他学材料
Katrina: He studies materials.
Katrina:  材料在中部的国企比较多
Katrina: There are more state-owned enterprises for materials in Central China.
Katrina:  他要留那我留我可能去杭州那边
Katrina: If he stays there, I might go to Hangzhou.
Katrina:  然后那就就就遥遥无期你知道吧
Katrina: And then it would just be endless, you know?
Katrina:  而且他也没有给我一个那种比较
Katrina: And he never gave me a decent plan.
Katrina:  稍微有像样子的规划
Katrina: Not even a slightly reasonable one.
Choiszt: 你谈恋爱这么认真吗就是
Choiszt: Do you take relationships this seriously?
Katrina: 啊是因为我觉得
Katrina: Yeah, because I feel like...
Shure: 5年了那种的嗯
Shure: It's been five years, right?
Shure:  废话
Shure: No kidding.
Choiszt: 那你现在觉得分分的对吗
Choiszt: So, do you think breaking up was the right move?
Katrina:  超爽
Katrina: Absolutely.
Katrina:  怎么不早分早分
Katrina: Why didn't we break up sooner?
Katrina:  哈哈当时也有人问我要微信啊
Katrina: Haha, people were asking for my WeChat back then too.
Shure:  当时有人跟我要微信啊
Shure: Yeah, people were asking for my WeChat too.
Nicous:  有有对象的时候也可以加微信
Nicous: You can add WeChat even if you're in a relationship.
Katrina: 没加没加
Katrina: I didn't add them, I didn't.
Choiszt: 这是你要加人微信的理由吗
Choiszt: Is that your reason for adding people on WeChat?
Shure:  咦谢冰竹你干什么
Shure: Hey, Xie Bingzhu, what are you doing?
Katrina:  大一的时候因为我自己也跟男生
Katrina: In freshman year, I hung out with guys a lot.
Katrina:  就是我性格比较像男生
Katrina: I guess I have a more guy-like personality.
Katrina:  我就高中也跟男生玩的比较多嘛
Katrina: Even in high school, I mostly played with guys.
Katrina:  所以我不管他异性朋友
Katrina: So, I didn't care about his female friends.
Katrina:  然后我就比较相信他那种
Katrina: I trusted him a lot.
Katrina:  然后大一的时候
Katrina: But in freshman year,
Katrina:  那女生就是他所谓的女闺蜜
Katrina: That girl, who he called his "bestie,"
Katrina:  就在他女在东华大学
Katrina: She was at Donghua University,
Katrina:  然后就社团喝醉酒了
Katrina: And she got drunk at a club.
Katrina:  就给他半夜打电话
Katrina: Just give him a call in the middle of the night.
Katrina:  然后他早上还问人家
Katrina: And then he would ask in the morning
Katrina:  有没有安全到学校那种
Katrina: if you got to school safely.
Katrina:  你我当时竟然都觉得没什么诶
Katrina: You know, back then I didn't even think it was a big deal.
Shure:  半夜打电话
Shure: Calling in the middle of the night.
Nicous:  三个人相处很好
Nicous: The three of them get along really well.
Shure:  只是半夜打电话而已
Shure: It's just calling in the middle of the night.
Shure:  没有半夜半夜半夜睡
Shure: Not like every night, every night, every night.
Shure:  睡到一起已经不错了你知道吧
Shure: Just sleeping together is already good, you know?
Katrina:  然后然后
Katrina: And then, and then...
Nicous: 真没睡真没睡
Nicous: Really didn't sleep, really didn't sleep.
Katrina: 诶当时就觉得诶无所谓
Katrina: Back then, I just felt like, whatever.
Shure: 虽然他给我送了我玫瑰花
Shure: Even though he gave me roses,
Shure: 但昨晚我真的没睡
Shure: I really didn't sleep last night.
Katrina: 他那件事那那个女生跟
Katrina: That thing, that girl,
Katrina: 东华大学那男朋友分手就要死要活啊
Katrina: broke up with her boyfriend from Donghua University and was like, dying.
Katrina: 什么要要自杀什么的啊
Katrina: Talking about suicide and stuff.
Katrina: 然后你现在就非要飞过去看他
Katrina: And now you just have to fly over to see her.
Katrina: 然后当时我就觉得很震惊
Katrina: And I was just so shocked.
Katrina: 我就不是
Katrina: I just wasn't...
Katrina: 你不应该稍微先问一下我吗
Katrina: Shouldn't you ask me first?
Katrina: 你怎么就在看票了然后
Katrina: Why are you just looking at the tickets and then...
Nicous: 他也得
Nicous: He has to...
Katrina: 我觉得那女生没闺蜜
Katrina: I think that girl has no best friend.
Katrina: 那女生好茶呀
Katrina: That girl is so manipulative.
Katrina: 什么事都来找他
Katrina: She goes to him for everything.
Katrina: 自己没闺蜜吗
Katrina: Doesn't she have her own best friend?
Katrina: 没爸妈吗
Katrina: Doesn't she have parents?
Shure: 谁到呢
Shure: Who is it?
Nicous: 你们三个人过好比谁都重要
Nicous: You three being together is more important than anything.
Katrina: 别笑话我了
Katrina: Don't make fun of me.
Katrina: 我真的是我
Katrina: I really am...
Katrina: 我可能就是第一次谈恋爱
Katrina: This might be my first relationship.
Katrina: 我不太懂那种
Katrina: I don't really understand...
Katrina: 就是什么时候是对的
Katrina: Like when things are right...
Katrina: 什么时候错的
Katrina: Or when they're wrong.
Katrina: 你知道吧
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 就所有的都觉得
Katrina: Just everything feels...
Alice: 这快递地址能发在群里吗
Alice: Can you send the delivery address in the group chat?
Katrina: 也不是忍吧就觉得呃
Katrina: It's not about enduring, just feels like, um...
Katrina: 就觉得会不会是有误会
Katrina: Feels like there might be a misunderstanding.
Katrina: 然后然后再一次
Katrina: And then again...
Katrina:  然后那次那那次就分手
Katrina: And then that time, that time we broke up.
Katrina:  然后不知道自己哄回来了
Katrina: And somehow I got him back.
Katrina:  哄回来给我买两支香奈儿口红还买错了
Katrina: He bought me two Chanel lipsticks to make up, but got the wrong ones.
Katrina: 买没错了
Katrina: Got the wrong ones.
Shure:  哄回来然后买两只香奈儿口红买错了然后还哄回来了
Shure: Got you back, bought two Chanel lipsticks, got the wrong ones, and still got you back.
Shure: 姑娘
Shure: Girl...
Nicous: 什么什么
Nicous: What, what?
Katrina: 就买
Katrina: Just bought...
Katrina: 买错口红
Katrina: Bought the wrong lipstick.
Katrina: 就是因为那次买错了
Katrina: Just because he bought the wrong one...
Katrina: 我们俩分手了
Katrina: We broke up.
Katrina: 他就是哄我然后买错了啊
Katrina: He tried to make up for it, but got the wrong one.
Choiszt: 就是色号买错了
Choiszt: Just got the wrong shade.
Katrina: 嗯都是叫82色号
Katrina: Yeah, it's called shade 82.
Katrina: 但是是两个系列
Katrina: But there are two series.
Katrina: 一个是唇膏一个是唇蜜
Katrina: One's a lipstick and one's a lip gloss.
Nicous: 卧槽这也能买错
Nicous: Damn, how can you get that wrong?
Nicous: 唇膏唇膏差有点多
Nicous: Lipstick and lip gloss are quite different.
Katrina: 我就觉得这
Katrina: I just feel like...
Katrina: 他干事很不踏实你知道吧
Katrina: He's really unreliable, you know.
Katrina: 很不用心呐那稍微看一下
Katrina: He's not very attentive, just take a look.
Katrina: 你看你连个中文日文都要比对一下对吧
Katrina: You even have to compare Chinese and Japanese, right?
Katrina:  我靠我从来没骂过人
Katrina: Gosh, I've never cursed at anyone.
Katrina: 包括他给我拍照哦前男友
Katrina: Even when he took photos of me, oh my ex-boyfriend.
Katrina: 拍照特别丑的时候我都没骂过
Katrina: Even when the photos were ugly, I never cursed.
Katrina:  因为我当时是这样想的
Katrina: Because I thought like this.
Katrina:  人家给你拍照也有苦就是
Katrina: He had his own struggles taking photos for you.
Choiszt:  没有功劳也有苦
Choiszt: Even if there's no credit, there are struggles.
Katrina:  嗯嗯就是
Katrina: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  我不会去骂人家对不对
Katrina: I wouldn't curse at him, right?
Katrina:  哎我觉得可p可p
Katrina: I think it could be edited.
Katrina:  或者就是哎
Katrina: Or, well...
Katrina:  没事大不了就不发这朋友圈啊
Katrina: It's okay, just don't post it on social media.
Katrina:  太懂事了
Katrina: So considerate.
Katrina:  谁他妈跟我谈
Katrina: Whoever dates me
Katrina:  真是有福了
Katrina: is really lucky.
Katrina:  从来没有骂过他
Katrina: I've never cursed at him.
Katrina:  然后包括我分手以后
Katrina: Even after we broke up.
Katrina:  我看我室友他们谈恋爱
Katrina: I saw my roommates in their relationships.
Katrina:  他们是直接就可能说话就比较直
Katrina: They just speak bluntly.
Katrina:  他们说哎你这样太邋遢太丑了
Katrina: They'd say, "Hey, you're so sloppy and ugly."
Katrina:  我靠从来没有说过带脏字的哎
Katrina: Gosh, I've never said anything with a curse word.
Katrina: 哦我当时觉得
Katrina: Oh, I used to think
Katrina: 最搞笑的是不会
Katrina: the funniest part is
Katrina: 我们俩吵架也不会骂人
Katrina: we wouldn't curse even when we fought.
Katrina: 就是但是会那种
Katrina: But we would...